[Music]
altered carbon is a new Netflix series
based off the 2002 novel the same name
it falls under the cyberpunk category
and please keep in mind with this review
I have not read the novel so please do
not leave any spoilers down below and
let's just keep that as a separate topic
I'm reviewing it totally as someone who
hasn't read it and just watching a TV
show so I'm gonna go through the pros of
the show first and I had a good amount
the first pro is the acting of some of
the leads the three actors have stood
out for me here we're Joel Kinnaman who
played Kovacs Arthur hick Rita who
played Ortega and Chris Connor who
played at ground PO I feel like for a
full season they did really good because
their acting was consistent all-around
top-notch and it was always believable
and the main actor Joel Kinnaman you've
seen him in not huge roles and other
stuff but I thought this really was kind
of his moment to shine I think he really
did and shocked me I didn't know how
good of an actor he was I think he
brought his a-game here it's always
complicated playing a character that is
different on the inside than on the
outside he really I felt like pulled it
off convincingly and it was always aware
of who he really was betraying the
visuals were astonishing obviously
looked a lot like Blade Runner and
watching it you're like I can't believe
this is TV now and that Netflix is
getting stuff like this effects why is
that is blockbuster movie quality there
I was putting a lot of money into their
television series and it really was a
spectacle to take in I feel like the
show constantly made me excited about
where the setting was gonna be in any
given scene which was something I
haven't had in a while and that one from
Poe's hotel to the streets that they're
in that look like Blade Runner and then
also in the flashbacks that whole world
they were in looked like from the video
game Halo like the force you would see
thought it all looked amazing another
Pro for me was Takashi's backstory as a
kid with his sister Rae and the abusive
father and how that all went about I
think the kid actors are really good and
it made you really start to sympathize
with Takashi Kovacs where at first I
wasn't so sure but when those flashbacks
kicked in it really gave the character
the depth that needed and also the setup
for what reg was to become this show to
me was really good on themes especially
the drama that could ensue if clones
ever exist so religious believes reverse
cloning and showing both sides of the
coin and this show makes a great case
for how
Vital death is in the human race because
people who didn't believe in death and
kept coming back and staying alive
through cloning and through backups in
the cloud they lived to become like
bancroft rich powerful no conscience or
like a who's just taken her traumas and
used him the wrong way and became a
really bad person so this show makes a
great case for why human death is so so
important to the way of life and how we
live and shape morally which I thought
that was interesting and how they made a
take on that and really put it out
convincingly the concept of stacks and
sleeves was really well done especially
the sleeves we've seen a lot of shows
and movies that use that way of
transferring human consciousness simply
black mirror I'm talking about you but I
thought the sleeve part was fun and
interesting and how they tackled that
because it was really cool not knowing
who was who at certain points and who to
trust and I could deceive people and any
given scene sometimes you were thinking
like is this really that person you make
guesses if you were right or wrong so
that was exciting it made it fun to
watch and now this is kind of
controversial opinion because a lot
people hate it but I really liked the
Wray reveal as the villain and that she
was actually a bad person it shocked me
I did not see it coming at all and I
liked that it made a complicated sibling
rivalry and it gave the villain depth
because a lot of villains are always
just like oh I rule the world or I want
to use this power to take over but she
was like that but she also loved her
brother wanted to be with her brother
who is the protagonist in this that we
like so what made it complicated for us
in a way to which Jimmy always adds some
new fresh take and more interesting in
more higher stakes and it's not so black
and white so for the season as a whole
episode wise the first three episodes I
thought were great I thought a guy you
excited for was to come and what was
gonna be I'll get to that middle patch
and the cons but I thought from episode
7 I believe it was where it was the flow
on full backstory episode and then the
Wray reveal the next episode I thought
from episode 7 on it did not let go and
I held on it was the best parts of the
show
I thought from that point it got better
and better as it went I thought it had
an incredible finale it wrapped up
everything great and we got battles who
wanted to see we got to see ravers
Kovacs at the same time we got to see or
take a verse ghost Walker what I loved
about the show which I was worried
seeing all these special effects in it
that we were also gonna get CGI type
battles what we didn't got so much hand
in hand
about which I always believe is the best
action it was really cool to see Lizzy
come through at the end and kick some
butt
and her action sequences in particular
really cool and I love our take I had
the arm that they added to her to give
her a little more of a advantage and
make more sense of her beating certain
people the best part of the season to me
was it felt like I had a beginning
middle and end and it added a lot of
questions but it answered most of them
and it felt like it was a complete
season a complete story and it set up
well for season 2 if I didn't think I
was gonna happen that we get all these
answers and resolve a lot of problems so
you really felt like you weren't
stringing along or trick you felt like
you got your reward for sitting through
a full 10 episodes of any show now the
cons of the show there was plenty of
those as well particularly for me
acting-wise the actress of Ray and the
actor of Vernon we're not good to me I
thought their performances here were
weak i specially thought Vernon and
Kovacs chemistry he was not pulling his
side of it and it didn't really work
maybe it was a Miss cast there it got
better as it went on towards the end but
first scenes we see Vernon I just wasn't
buying his character I don't think he
even knew what his character really was
about at a certain time so wasn't
convincing to me and the actress of Ray
was very wooden and she didn't show a
lot of emotion in her face and she
needed to bring a good performance here
because she was such a complicated
character someone were supposed to kind
of like in the beginning and now we
don't like what's her motivation how she
betraying it and I feel like she didn't
have enough emotion here another con I
had here was it had a lot of very
confusing dialogue and they threw a lot
at you through dialogue at once and it
was overwhelming I felt like it parts it
worked but in other parts it was just
not clear and a lot of scratching her
head and a lot of having to rewind it
felt like work watching it sometimes
there's a thing here where you can set
up mysteries and set up a little bit of
purpose confusion and I think West
world's a show that does that really
really well
however this show I don't think that as
well there's difference between again
having mysteries that make sense of why
there is a mystery than actually just
blatantly confusing to confuse Jeff OTT
this showed it a lot and it made sense
in the end
but it didn't do it away to get the
viewer to understand it enough to
understand why am i curious about this
or why is this happening it was very
just messy and the reason it is so messy
is because if you go on the reddit for
altered
you'll see people commenting certain
questions they had about certain choices
characters made that they didn't agree
with or didn't understand why they did
it and every time someone answers a
question like that in the forum they
would write I think first so it wasn't
even like there was clear explanations
for certain dialogue that was said that
was a little hard to that we're having
conversation or people saying I think it
meant this I think they meant that where
those should be parts we should just
know so again it's not a matter of oh
there's too many questions of mystery
it's more of like oh no there's just too
many questions of something that we
should already know the answer to it's
just not clear there was two examples
for me where I felt confused and don't
understand why a certain thing happened
the first one for me was the attorney
Prescott
because when Kovacs uses her to frame
her we know she's not a good person we
know she's trying to suck up to the
higher-ups and cover for them but I
thought even her being framed for that
was a little too harsh in her and I kind
of felt bad for I know she's not a good
person but I didn't believe the
character of Kovacs would actually do
that and use her in that case when she
really didn't cause that murder to
happen so I thought that didn't make any
sense to me
and then people who answered me on the
forums about it were just like oh she
was an obnoxious person and was just
kissing up to them or do anything yeah
but that doesn't deserve punishment
being framed for a murder which our
protagonist is doing were supposed to
like and understand his motivations in
some sense that it's a just thing he is
doing so you know someone drew for it
and I didn't think it was a after me off
a bit another thing I saw a lot of
people getting confused about was in the
finale Bancroft gets arrested found out
his wife drugged him though so he was
drugged when he killed that girl again
he wasn't a good guy at all he was into
weird stuff he's rich powerful corrupt
but he was still drugged for what he got
arrested for so doesn't that mean he
wasn't technically in the wrong like he
was taken advantage of and put in a
different state that was a little not
making sense to me there to get arrested
for that or maybe at least make it a
trial that they set up for him and just
felt like oh he's arrestees I'm
complaining like hey I was drugged like
oh okay I screwed up or that felt just
off my biggest con was this middle patch
here in the show that was about episodes
3 through 6 we got a lot of flashback
scenes of Kovach's love interest quell
crista Falcone er
giving speech after
beach that's really corny and cheesy and
that's when it felt like a sci-fi
channel which only resists TV show it
was just cheesy over-the-top corny so on
the nose all her speeches felt like that
her character felt off from the whole
beat of the show and what everyone else
was like and the worst episode for me
this season was the torture episode
because it was so bothersome and very
amateur to have her character explaining
how to be simulated torture while it's
also happening in the episode oh he's
remembering all the stuff she said but
it's just so here you go on a plate for
you it's not anything that gets your
mind going or works in an effective way
viewing it was just almost playing like
a book and I know it's based off a book
but you got to change that up a bit so
that was very lazy writing to me but a
lot of that wasn't even necessary just
show his main flashback episode which I
actually did like the full flashback one
cuz he even showed some of the old
speeches that weren't that great but
just have that episode don't even show
those other flashbacks yet I didn't like
her character in general quokkas Falcone
she's just over the top and just robotic
there's no emotion I like the actress
here anything it was her fault I just
thought the writing for that character
is just weak especially was gonna be the
main love interest here another problem
I had here too was the ravers Ortega
fight the many clones of Rae coming out
the problem and this is was Ortega was
able to take out like six of these rays
but the episode prior Rae saved Ortega
and Kovacs and looked like an amazing
fighter in Episode killing a bunch of
these people super advanced and you're
like oh my god who is this you find out
ray and you're like wow she's really
trained former envoi and six of her
loose Ortega come on that was not
believable at all and really the rest of
the way Ray's character that sequence we
got of her saving Kovacs in that Fight
Club area she never shows that type of
skill again not consistent on that part
like if you're gonna show her opening
intro to curtain time be this great of a
fighter and then when we see her again
from there on she's not that good so
that was a little off to me and that
scene where she saves them at the Fight
Club why would she even go herself in
this like incognito costume she's so
rich why wouldn't she just send someone
else so she wouldn't risk her life and
then they do the reveal of her being a
villain with them being brought to her I
thought that would
been more effective and believable it
just felt like that whole scene was shot
really early and wasn't planned out well
with the rest of the show and the whole
incest vibes out she was giving off not
necessarily Kovacs but her character the
scene with the bathtub where she was
gonna take his body and she's always has
this weird jealousy of the woman I get
when his sister wants to be protective
and doesn't want these woman to take
away her brother from her but they made
it also a lustful thing and a weird
sexual thing and that was so unnecessary
to me and it made her motives very
confusing because you're like wait is
she of her brother as a brother or is
she in love with her brother and that
was just creepy and weird because I
don't think that was the end game but it
kind of came off that way and I think
the Lizzy character was really cool at
the end how she came and kicked butt but
we don't know anything about her pretty
much a hollow character and that sucking
a little thing is way overdone in so
many sci-fi aspects and her being there
I just thought it was annoying and
unnecessary and it was also my problem
with this middle patch of the season is
I think they dragged on the Bancroft
mystery too long I didn't care about it
at a point you're like six episodes in
like why do I care if you solve this
mystery I know he wants me his freedom
but it was just no attachment that's why
I did like the Ray reveal as a villain
because then I felt okay this is her
sister this is more emotion to it this
makes much more sense so there was that
drag there for sure so those are my pros
and cons I had a lot of both but I'm
gonna give this a 7.5 it was very
ambitious it felt fresh shirt there was
a lot of touches to old sci-fi movies
and TV shows and takes from them but it
didn't in a new way it felt like a new
world they were game-changing special
effects here especially for a Netflix
show it was super entertaining most of
the time and there's a lot of depth to
this story there really was and it
wrapped it up so tight which I really
respect now because the last shows don't
do that anymore especially in a season
one and it was able to do that and set
up a season two so really props for that
I have question for you guys did you
like the Rach whist as the villain also
they say at the end that Kovacs is gonna
give his sleeve up and use a different
one because Riker didn't do anything
wrong and it looks like he's gonna go to
work tag and they're gonna clean up a
lot of these characters now that we were
used to but do you think Kovacs is gonna
be in a new sleeve for sure next season
is gonna be a different actor no more
Joel Kinnaman and will that happen if
that does who would you want to see play
Kovacs next season and of course please
give me your rating in the show if you
Gru's me let me know if you
agree let me know I love all opinions
they respond to everybody so please
comment below and please subscribe to my
channel
I review a bunch of TV shows movies I do
celebrity interviews with the actors
themselves and I'd love to hear from you
so please keep coming back follow me at
Steve rd1 on Twitter and Instagram and
I'll see you next time